thank you so much for joining us i'm
john langler and today is valentine's
day it's also national donor day this
morning nevada's donor network hosted a
drive in memory of fallen nevada state
police trooper micah may as hector mejia
reports trooper may's organs were
donated after he was killed in the line
of duty last year
last july nevada state trooper micah may
was killed by a suspect in a pursuit on
the i-15 through the gift of organ
donation the fallen troopers saved the
lives of three people he gave so much
the fact that he was able to
donate and
still serve the community after he
passes
i really hope they understand how much
that means joanna may is trooper may's
widow he left behind a little daughter
and a four-year-old son he'll drive his
car and he'll be like it's daddy's car
and he'll pull over
in the road and just start crying
and say i miss daddy
but he
he doesn't fully understand but he knows
according to the nevada donor network
there are a hundred thousand people in
the u.s currently waiting for a second
chance through organ donation about 600
of them in nevada over 60 percent of our
state is registered to be organ eye and
tissue donors the national average is
only about 54 percent on national donor
day they held a registration drive in
honor of trooper may outside of the
southern command headquarters everything
that had happened was very tragic
but the fact that there's a spark of
sunlight out of that is what helps me
get through you can sign up to become an
organ donor at the dmv or online at
registerme.org hector mejia live local
now